is this now the end of police based
reality shows because cops one of the
longest-running TV shows has been
cancelled in the wake of George Boyd's
death cops became a ratings hit and
cultural phenomenon in the late 80s and
90s et was invited behind the scene let
me see what part of the concept of the
show was to show that we're human beings
also that we have problems like everyone
else
it's 33rd season was set to premiere
next Monday but the Paramount networking
noun tells et that's not happening and
we don't have any current or future
plans for it to return why people yellow
people brown people if everybody's
getting arrested you can have cops it
just feels like it's a whole bunch of
black people all the time then not
against cops that it was always
portraying the police as the heroes when
camera crews are embedded with police
officers
it sometimes affects how the police
officers behave that's been a critique
for many years and I think the network
is belatedly acknowledging that critique
now that cops has been canceled the show
live PD is also coming under scrutiny
live PD premiered in 2016 and is now the
number one series on cable in its
timeslot
any pulled episodes in the wake of
George Floyd's death and now a source
close to the show tell ZT Live PD will
not air this weekend while network execs
determine next steps and when it will
return real-life stuff serious stuff
post Dan Abrams tweeted to all of you
asking whether live PD is coming back
the answer is yes we are still
discussing some specifics but we are not
abandoning you it gets a little bit
hairy because we still have to behave
responsibly but now the show is under
fire after it was involved in a fatal
incident last year warning it's
disturbing
havi Rambler was pursued by Texas
deputies for failure to dim his
headlights he avoided sheriff's until he
crashed his car he was tased and held
down as he pled for mercy the unarmed 40
year old father who told officers he had
a heart condition was tased a total of
four times he didn't recover no
authorities were charged live pd did not
air or release their footage it was only
after a recent outcry that police
released one officers body cam video on
Monday he tells et neither it nor the
producers of live PD were asked for the
footage and as is our practice when
investigations conclude we no longer
retain unaired footage the DA has opened
a new investigation of the sheriff's one
of the critiques of live PD is that it
oversimplifies the story and only shows
you the police officers point of view
but you know at the same time it shows
how dangerous the profession sometimes
is so that's the balancing act I think
the network has to be making right now
he shows can't be improved there's no
other side to this argument it is
irresponsible in at any moment but
especially at this moment in American
history
to keep it on the air and continue to
foment the type of anger and pain and
trauma that so many Americans are
feeling right now
[Music]